the jurogan experience like
don't live in the white house jamie i'm
going to send you some [ __ ]
ain't no goddamn politician go to the
hood cory booker dude
marion barry did he smoke correct yes
[Laughter]
you know why uh i met marion barry when
he was uh
just reelected he was just realized that
that's crazy
after the crack yeah after the correct
94 yeah
um jamie i just uh the crack is back
there yeah yeah
it was in 94 maybe it was after i don't
know
it was um i was in the uh studio
it disappeared it was only available for
a second i think i texted it to you
though
man set me up
set me up you were smoking crack though
bro this is what happened
we were sitting in the studios me and
jim norton and obie and anthony and i
forget who else was a guest
but marion barry was walking right by
this this big glass doors at siriusxm
and uh he was just walking right by he
was on some other show
someone go go grab him go grab him get
him in here so we open up the door
and marion barry just walks right in and
he sits down
and uh and and then is he gone is he
dead
yeah he died he's dead okay recipes mary
you one of the most famous crack smoking
ass [ __ ] so
of all time i'm sitting there and i know
i know i got a couple seconds
with this dude and so all my predatory
instincts kick in
and i'm like we gotta get right to this
they're gonna pull them out of here yeah
as soon as they know what this show's
all about
because we're a bunch of comedians we're
[ __ ] high it's uh
seven o'clock in the morning i was high
as [ __ ] dude i was eating pot lollipops
and [ __ ]
and i was like i go what what i i we
talked about him smoking crack
and one of the i bring i brought it up
right really quick but he said he goes
hold on no one knows what's in that pipe
that's what he said
no one knows that's diplomatic
diplomatic that's badass
no one knows what's going on wow that
means
i would vote for that guy because that's
a hell of a politician it's a good move
i like what he's saying but it's really
i like how he's trying to do it you know
what i'm saying he's like no that's
tobacco
you know it's like no one knows what's
in a hot dog
right you know i mean you see the bun
you see the hot dog
you tell can you give in what what
percentage would you get correct in
terms of
ingredients right though like right now
if they give you a test i wouldn't even
oh my god i wouldn't even i'd be like oh
yeah so that was it oh there's an audio
and so that crack story started with
that
but there's been no evidence that i
don't we don't know what was in it
i mean i was up there for some other
reason quite frankly what did you think
was that
oh i took one drag on it okay do you
feel that they were trying to railroad
you because they didn't like it
what year was did he get caught smoking
correct that's a good question
and who he had a camera here's the yeah
i don't think anybody did but here's the
thing
so what what if he was just drinking
right though because he was trying to
listen
all the things he just said there now
i've changed my perspective since this
happened
getting older and more experienced in
life
yeah but also realizing like hey the guy
if he did a good job as mayor who gives
a [ __ ] if he gets high
right if he gets home and shooting
heroin he's got a butt plug up his ass
and
oculus rift on right and he's tripping
balls on kevin
why do i give a [ __ ] if this is this guy
safe in education
right is he is he providing health care
is he making it safer for people is he
bringing people together
right is he letting people know hey we
have more in common
that try to kill me fbi tried to kill me
well he they might have that's the how
did they have that the bbi's killed a
lot of people
yeah that's the governor of dc yeah yeah
who hit the camera that's what i want to
know who had the camera
like willie d said you gotta let a hobby
a hoe yeah sometimes
and sometimes some gals need a little
money they'll hide a camera
cool this is what you got to do
stupid ass [ __ ] hear the camera we
ain't smoking crack [ __ ] yeah all this
good crack in here you want to have a
camera
and the thing is i mean like for the
most part it's just like he's partying
he's just like hey listen man why is it
old man why is it bad yeah does he [ __ ]
up his job
here's the thing if he shows up monday
morning he's cracked out and decides to
nuke china
you know just what kind of bombs we got
you're like
okay okay okay yeah if he's a real yeah
if he's like a
degenerate crackhead but he wasn't he
was a what if he just functioning
but what if he just sits in a chair what
if he sits in the chair
what if he's got a lazy boy and he puts
his feet up and he just keeps
pounding that's like you're uh keeps
pounding whiskey
yeah he just gets no way worse than that
guy what if he just he's doing what's
legal
but he's in a chair and he's just not
going anywhere just
pounding it how come that's okay we'll
talk about the effects of crack credit
credit freddie crack cracked out freddie
tell me about the effects of crack i
mean everybody everybody handled drugs
differently man so you know
what put that up there dear jamie says
marion barry
76 says further down in the interview
that he believes the fbi was trying to
get him
to smoke a substance as high as 90
percent pure cocaine
damn damn and chemistry chemist
at uh barry's subsequent trial testified
that the drug used in the sting
operation
was in fact 93 pure cocaine
holy [ __ ] so they might have been they
might the catfished him
yeah they might have been trying to get
him to die well i'm gonna tell you this
right oh my god look at this they had an
emt on the spot
which is not only did try to kill him
for real yeah
not only unusual but rare in the history
of the fbi
barry noted as he offered evidence to
support his claims the fbi attempted to
kill me
why would they have an emt on the same
on the scene if they weren't trying
um fbi officials said that wow we had to
let him inhale
it says at the bottom the fbi official
says the purpose of the medical standby
was to provide potential medical
attention to marion barry
should his criminal activities require
it these criminal activities that they
brought the [ __ ]
coke for they made this big
being said about the fbi they only talk
about weird these are people trying to
[ __ ] kids
wow
and they don't they don't hang out with
you they don't hang out with people that
are interested in that or that story
you know we people hang out with if
you're hanging around with a bunch of
flat earthers
that believe that uh there's a basement
somewhere where all the kids get [ __ ]
right that's all you think about all day
long but that actually happened to mary
and barry
you don't have time to listen to cornell
west
you don't have time we're just reading
fbi but you know what i'm saying it's
like you you're so
wrapped up in your own [ __ ] yeah
you're so wrapped up and being tribal
you don't have time
i thought that probably
me listening to him talking about us
changed my perspective i bet
and you know also me listening to me
describe the video that i saw
where all these people are like nothing
wrong with my little crack every now and
then like i remember seeing
that i remember i remember thinking at
the time these people are crazy
they they re-elected him and look they
don't care about crap get it right
now as a grown man who understands media
i realize oh no
there's probably like a broad range of
opinions
there's probably a lot of people that go
hey what do you give a [ __ ]
if he's smoking crack if he does a great
job with the budget yeah i don't know if
he did
who gives a [ __ ] i don't know if he did
i don't i literally know nothing about
the guys yeah don't re-elect him
exactly what they did though right they
did yeah but i don't think was he bad so
i'm trying to figure out maybe they
missed him
maybe the new guy got in place and he
was boring and maybe marion did a
good job and smoked crack right that's
possible too
right like bert christopher he's a funny
comedian
and he's a drunk okay i was gonna say i
was like right burst must crack
no no how much is
how much is there a difference well
one's illegal that's it that's it
exactly that's the only difference
i don't know if he did a good job i
don't know but let's assume he did
but if he didn't do a good job you
should be mad at him for the job that he
did that he [ __ ] up
not for the fact that someone who set
him up busted him
smoking crack with [ __ ] emt camera an
emt crew behind them hey this shit's
fire bro like you need to stay okay just
in case he has a heart attack like linda
that's crazy
that's like that's limb scale coca they
gave him meanwhile
how hilarious is it that because
cocaine's illegal
93 percent is crazy high right
it is but i want to know
how do they get your naked virus that's
90 percent i imagine if you got 93
vodka where's my where's my vodka [ __ ]
seven percent is water you [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's coors light yeah i want to know how
they got that in a
how they [ __ ] they got that in a crack
recipe yeah 93 percent cocaine cause
[ __ ]
chemistry it's it's mostly soda right
now that's crazy mostly that was that
one crack he was smoking he was smoking
cocaine
well he thought it's the same thing
according to
carl hurst was weird he's just like well
coco puffs ain't nothing you know it's
different
and you ain't gonna [ __ ] with this
it's also different in like where you're
doing it
right in the hotel room i mean if you're
in vegas and you're in a [ __ ] suite
and you're overlooking the neon signs
and you're doing coke
yeah you're doing coke catch new
episodes of the joe rogan experience for
free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly
switch between video and audio
experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre in the
background while using other apps and
can download episodes to save on data
cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre
episodes you just need to search for the
jre on your spotify app
go to spotify now to get this full
episode
of the joe rogan experience